- Okay, so here we are.
Here's another episode of Eating Your Feed.
So, we have both been on here before.
- Yeah.
- I saw you boil the peach.
^That was pretty neat.
^- Who knew peaches looked like that on the inside?
Yeah, I had no idea what I was doing in there.
^- If I'm gonna be forced to make this show, Adam,
this is gonna be a little bit of a weird one.
^We're gonna do this thing called a timpano.
^Basically, it looks like this stretched animal skin
^over a bucket of meats, pastas, sauces.
^Eggs go in there, that's kinda crazy,
^and then you kinda fold that dough over
^and you bake the whole thing off.
We've seen it on this show called Binging with Babish,
awesome food show online.
He made it based on
one of my favorite movies called Big Night.
New York Times did a version.
Chef I love, David Chang,
posted his own version on Instagram recently.
- Whoa.
- It's crazy, yeah.
So, as always, we're going to bring on Rie.
I think we're not gonna make our own fresh pasta
except for the shell.
We'll make our own meatballs, sauce,
Italian sausages, stuffed shells.
Anything that we should look out for?
- Make a solid game plan.
(laughing)
- This is the biggest pot that we have available to us
^here at Tasty right now.
^I think I wanna go a little bit bigger than this.
^- Sure.
^- We'll make a real thick one with two c's.
- So, we're gonna go get our stuff now.
^- Look at the thing.
- Boom, look at that.
Alright, let's get started, yeah.
You do the tomato sauce in this and I'm gonna take this guy
and fire off the mushroom ragu.
- I'm ready to get into the paste.
- The paste?
- The paste, right?
- You're making the tomato sauce.
- Sauce, why did I call it paste?
- I don't know.
- I'm just Google searching Buzfeed tomato sauce.
- I'm gonna start cutting an onion up (groans)
- Oh, wow, yeah.
- It's the one time I get to cry.
So, my mushroom recipe...
I don't think I bought all of the right ingredients
for any one particular recipe.
So, I'm just kind of making it up
and combining a bunch of them.
- A pound of spaghetti, but we're not doing that right now.
Yeah, we ain't gotta worry about that.
Get the hunk of parm.
- I don't think you need...
- We don't need the hunk of parm either.
- Cut this up.
- Great, thank you.
- Put it in the pot
- Yes.
- when it's hot,
- This is what I need.
- and then the other (bleep) goes in.
That's it, that's it.
How much butter do I need, I don't know.
- So, I'm just gonna chop this in half.
This is appropriate, right?
- What are you doing there?
- Choppin' this up!
- So, you take your knife
and you cut almost all the way through.
Each of these is a distinct strand like that,
so when I cut this way, then you got a little cube.
You ready for this?
Pinching it together, you go boom, and now look at that.
This is the shape of your onion.
Next we're gonna do garlic.
- Alright, where's our sink?
- It's in the other room.
- Like most kitchens, it's in the other room.
^- Shit-ache.
Salt, more mushrooms.
How's it going, pal?
- We're gettin' there, man.
- I'm going to add a little bit of tomato paste,
I'm gonna add an anchovy,
and then I'm gonna deglaze that with brandy.
Okay, it smells really fishy.
- Opened up our tomatoes.
Look at how mushed up they are, look at that!
This is weird, I'll tell you what.
- Is it?
- Okay, so we have olive oil, salt, pepper,
onion, garlic, and carrot.
^Trying to get that umami flavor, right?
- I'm gonna throw some rosemary in my mushroom ragu here
because why not, you know?
- [Patrick] And then pretty soon
^we're gonna add our anchovies here.
- I'm really trying to make this look cool.
- Next, add the crushed red pepper flakes
and the tomato paste.
It's such color.
- I swear, that's my first bowl of wine.
Let it spill over, don't stop pouring.
Tip it and keep going.
I love the double steam columns
we've got comin' off of here, you know?
It's like our two turntables, like Daft Punk.
- [Patrick] Addin' our tomato.
- I'm adding fish sauce to this.
I think it's just gonna add a smack of depth to it.
You won't even know it's there.
- Okay, I mean, I trust you.
- Alright, so I'm happy with where
the mushroom ragu's at for now.
You want a bite, Adam?
- It's like Christmas.
- It's delicious.
- There's no comparison here.
I mean, this is...
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- People are gonna be
talking about your sauce more than they talk about my sauce.
- Get the heck outta here.
- Now we're gonna make some meatballs.
This is a hilariously large bowl.
- [Patrick] We got ground beef here and our ground pork.
- Throwin' some onion in here.
Crack two eggs right in there.
- Cheese and juice.
- [Andrew] I like a pretty green in my meatballs.
I'm gonna preemptively add some bread crumbs.
^- [Patrick] I don't even recall buying that.
- I slipped it in at the last moment.
- Sneaky.
- Splash of milk in here.
Alright, start squeezing those around.
- You got it, pal.
I mean, I love what you added in here last minute.
The milk, the other thing that I can't remember.
- Let's start rolling these up.
Oh, that's a big meatball.
You know what, that's okay.
- That is a big boy.
- Boom, that's a tray of meatballs if I've ever seen 'em.
Oh (laughs) okay.
I'll just wash my hands, it's okay.
And so, these guys are goin' in.
End of day one.
Mushroom ragu is done, we got our tomato sauce,
oh, we gotta pull our meatballs out of the oven.
- Yeah, the whole thing.
- [Andrew] I am giddy with joy right now.
- I'm happy that you're excited, quite honestly.
I might wear a suit tomorrow, I'm so...
I wanna impress this meal.
- Let's invite Rie on to check out
what's been goin' on all day.
- Yeah, it's so good!
- Okay, so today's the big day.
We gotta cook our pasta, we're gonna make stuffed shells,
cook sausages, and make boiled eggs.
We also have to make the whole crust.
So, we've got our sausages here.
I'm just gonna...
Three hot, three mild.
These are hefty.
We're just gonna bake these.
This recipe comes from the Binging with Babish video.
We're just gonna use his recipe for the crust
to ensure that we have enough dough to fill our timpano.
Adam just asked if service here
goes up proportionally to volume.
I just don't know where to start with that question.
Is it safe to assume that we should just
increase the recipe by 50%?
- Yeah, just do it and we'll see what's gonna happen.
- So, we're gonna do 30 ounces of Double 0 Flour,
four whole eggs, and 12 yolks.
I'm actually really bad at cracking eggs.
Okay, see, we're gonna have a bad time here.
Oh, I'm cracking, I'm cracking, it's going in.
- That was 11,
do you wanna do the last one?
- Here's 12!
Do you want some egg whites?
Maybe somebody wants this for lunch.
We're just gonna pour out our dough, make a little well,
pour our eggs in, a little squirt of salt.
I'm gonna add a little bit of olive oil.
Oh, god, this is a....
- Oh, boy.
- I didn't do this right.
- Um...
- What, what's wrong?
- [Rie] Oh, no, nothing, nothing is wrong.
It's okay.
- It's there.
Let's just go for it, there's no going back now.
Can't control z this moment.
- Oh, okay, that feels great.
Oh, God, can somebody check the sausages?
Alright, our sausage is cooked.
So, the dough feels pretty dry,
so we're gonna add an egg to get some more moisture in there
and try to get this thing together.
We're totally in the dark here, you know?
At some point, I'll be out of this,
but right now it sucks and I cannot see the light.
So, last time we did a bad job
of making sure all the eggs were incorporated
before trying to get all of the flour together,
so we're gonna make another batch,
but tackle it in two separate smaller batches.
Rie's gonna help with one of them.
- I think you gonna use flour little by little.
- [Andrew] Alright, this looks like fun,
so I'm gonna get started over here.
- [Patrick] Yeah, this looks great.
- Sometimes depends on the size of egg,
maybe he's using large egg and our egg is small.
- It's extremely sticky, I don't know how you did this.
This makes a whole lot more sense.
I can already see why this is the way you do it.
^- Yeah.
- Oh, that's beautiful.
^- Isn't that beautiful?
- Good.
- We don't suck.
- Eggs are about done.
- Next, we're gonna be making some dumbo shells.
I'm gonng make the filling for the stuffed shells now.
I'm gonna kind of make it up.
^I want ricotta, mozzarella, parmensan, and some herbs,
maybe a squeeze of lemon.
Yeah, that's it.
- Brighten it up a little bit
with that lemon.
- Brighten it up!
Oops.
- [Patrick] Geeze, look at that.
- Looks like apple sauce.
- Mhm.
- Let's start boiling some pasta.
What else could I sneak in here?
- A pasta spoon, what is a pasta spoon?
- Rigatoni pot lookin' hot.
Alright, I'm gonna start filling shells.
I've never done this before.
It's basically a savory cannoli.
Oh, sorry.
I might be overfilling them slightly, so...
Oh, nice job with these eggs.
Oh my God, just rolling your hands through a bunch of eggs.
- If I were to direct a music video, I would be like,
so the concept is hard boiled eggs in a bathtub,
and we're just gonna go crazy.
- Alright, alright, alright.
Timpano dough roll out.
This is one of the most satisfying looking things.
Woo hoo!
Unclear whether we have enough dough.
I think it'll be fine.
- [Patrick] Gonna line our dutch oven
with butter and olive oil.
- We're gonna start rollin' this thing on.
Okay, let's get the pot in.
- [Patrick] Nice, dude.
- [Andrew] I'm gonna gently push it into the sides.
- Yes!
- Great, nice.
- Alright, you wanna start scooping rigatoni in?
- Sure.
- Almost half of the pasta didn't make a dent.
I'm worried about how much stuff we have.
Let's grate some of that cheese right into there.
- Pecorino Romano.
- Ray Romano.
I'm gonna start doing meatballs now.
I think we should split them in half
so that we get an even layer of them.
Let's do a little bit of tomato sauce.
- Smell that.
- Yeah, I wanna see an even blanket of that.
Oh, we're gonna run out of space, actually.
Soft shells next.
- Okay.
- Are we gonna have enough, I really hope so.
We'll just kinda do a little bit of cheese
along the sides here, fill it in a little bit.
- [Patrick] We got the sausages.
- Alright, let's just fill in these cracks with eggs, right?
Okay, we'll just have a couple leftover eggs for a snack.
- Someone's gonna have a really eggy part of this timpano.
- Yeah, there's no way this won't taste good.
Grating a little more pecorino on there.
Now we're just havin' fun, I feel like Bob Ross.
Leftovers, we have three eggs, one meatball,
and like a quarter cup of pasta.
How should we fold this together?
- Dude, I gotta try it once.
What am I doing standing here?
Look at this thing!
Oh my God.
- That's like a solid 45 pounds.
(laughing)
Alright, let's get this bad boy in the oven.
Okay, it's been about 50 minutes to an hour.
We're gonna take the lid off.
Maybe we shouldn't have put the butter on top.
- It's too brown?
- It's getting brown a little early.
- You think it's gonna burn?
- I don't know.
An hour and a half in on the timpano bake.
A little bit concerned about the browning happening on top,
so we put some foil,
which I think will help deflect the heat.
I'm gonna go on the record as saying
I think a little danger adds a lot of excitement to a meal.
It's been over two hours now.
- Yes, yes.
- Oh, it's perfect!
- Great.
- We're gonna call that done.
We're going to unmold it.
Tell me about it, Adam.
Alright, here it comes, no hesitation.
(all cheering)
Oh, yeah.
- That looks perfect.
- I just wanna stand here and fan it, you know?
I'm like, cool down already.
We can eat it now?
- Come on, everybody.
Gather round for this feast.
(cheering)
- Alright, let's get in there with a knife.
- [Patrick] I support you.
I give you my props here.
- I think you've just
gotta commit.
- Come on.
(all talking)
Oh, it's juicy.
- [Patrick] Here we go.
Oh boy, oh boy.
- Okay, the moment of truth.
You guys ready for this?
- Hell yeah.
- [Woman] What's inside?
- Oh, nice.
(cheering)
- Look at that, yeah, well done.
There it is, yeah.
I cannot believe it.
- [Andrew] I swear to god, if this falls on the ground...
- [All] Cheers.
- Earlier in the video, I drank from a bowl.
Yeah, make it rain.
That's the timpano.
(clapping)
- [Patrick] Well done.
- Mm!
Holy crap.
- Yeah, for real.
- Its like a surprise in every bite.
- I think this is the best thing you have ever made.
- Rie gives it a blessing.
I would probably leave the eggs out next time though.
I don't know why the eggs are there, I don't know why.
- The meatball is great.
- That ragu is just out of this world.
- This is actually really good.
Surprisers.
(laughing)
- [Andrew] That's gonna happen with a timpano.
I think that was a great success.
- [Patrick] Thank you, Babish.
- [Andrew] I wouldn't not make it again.
- [Patrick] I would love to make this again,
are you kidding me?
This would be fun.
- Yeah, it was a great time.
- It's just too much work.
(upbeat music)